welcome to this video playing tiga Olga
from Germany the eye of the tiger not
going to sing this now for various
reasons one being that the German game i
would probably strike and take down the
video ok um benoni Jima is the German
it's a company that looking at rights on
music so I'm famously we very often in
Germany cannot do popular music clips on
youtube because jima has taken them down
so big difference to the u.s. it seems
that YouTube has many music videos and
then now Germany it's not happening that
often because of this the Sun rights
issue ok the modern benoni TM and turn
got this night to Jeffrey and now I'm
hoping for my usual business here with
the bishop h6 trying to exchange and
he's not really am not really preventing
that so I'm going to exchange the bishop
ok take it and he's ready for be fire
but I can I can set up for the before'
counter counter stroke and will do so
yeah this nicely blocks the whole Queen
side and if you go see for I have a free
hand in the center and probably with our
foyer I'm going to go into play a form
would like to get the night to do follow
though okay you can't have it all um
maybe bishop f 392 d for now after f6
this I can put it maybe put it on c2
actually it's maybe the better better
way to go once the two it also covers
before but it has a more more active
orientation towards the King side
Bishop on b7 is so is not really doing
that much
yeah well I put the knight on d4 and
then see what happens he really does not
have any substantial counterplay this
before move by white is a very common
countermeasure against the queenside
expansion now as pawns are blocked the
night on this route c 3 is always
checking and pressurizing the b5 porn
and there is really not that much that
that black can do yeah i can go f5 and
plant an idea i will do so this is just
good plot the night only six check ok
I'm going to take with the pawn here
opening up the F file and there's also
Queen D for coming and then f6 queen d
fight it does not really have a great
square Abbott now it's it's good it's
good does not need to do not need to
look for anything fancy here if five
maybe I can also take it and look f1 but
it's not yet convincing if i go here I'm
threatening rook g5 as well and second
rook
yeah that's a total control position um
I v5 as well and also be five hangs mmm
yeah maybe take b5 here yeah let's take
that we should be one I thought simply
you tell that this was I this was really
hopeless it sometimes really happens a
bit noni is an opening that's very
sensitive if you make one or two
mistakes it will be a very very
one-sided game I don't know I actually
think that blacks position has already
rather bad after the bishop is gone
white has just better play in the center
b5 is always counted with this and after
this this is a strategical wynia for
white it's just too much it's too much I
can also maybe start with Luke a one but
okay it's it just just a total
domination in the center and here it's a
matter of taste but f5 is very good
because 9075 which is the normal
argument against this is far away here
and you get to simply get check and get
everything that you want here from a
position yeah okay thanks for watching